TODAY WE ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT BENEDICT ARNOLD.
BENEDICT ARNOLD WAS A GENERAL
IN THE AMERICAN REVOLUTION.
HE'S A HERO OF SARATOGA,
BUT THE CONTINENTAL CONGRESS
PROMOTED FIVE OTHER GENERALS
AND NOT BENEDICT ARNOLD.
BENEDICT ARNOLD
WAS VERY BUMMED OUT BY THAT,
SO HE GOES TO PHILADELPHIA.
THERE'S A YOUNG WOMAN,
PEGGY SHIPPEN,
WHO IS THE IT GIRL
OF PHILADELPHIA.
PEGGY WAS LIKE,
I'M HILARIOUS, I'M BRITISH,
AND I'M THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
PERSON THAT ANYONE'S EVER SEEN.
SHE HAS A SUITOR
NAMED JOHN ANDRE,
BUT BENEDICT SEES HER AND JUST
FALLS CRAZY IN LOVE WITH HER
AND TELLS HER,
IT'S BETTER WITH YOU--
THIS IS NOT AN EXACT QUOTE.
IT'S BETTER--
YOU ARE SO GREAT.
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
YOU'RE SO GREAT.
SO SHE MARRIES BENEDICT ARNOLD,
WHO I BELIEVE SHE ALSO LOVED.
OH, GOD.
- WHAT?
- I JUST REALIZED
THAT I WAS BEING FILMED.
[both laugh]
- MY GOD.
- SO, ANYWAY, PEGGY SAYS,
SWEETHEART, YOU DESERVE TO BE
BACKED BY THE GOVERNMENT
THAT YOU BELONG TO.
YOU KNOW, THE BRITISH...
WOULD APPRECIATE YOU.
THEY WOULD LOVE YOU.
ALSO, MY FAMILY'S BRITISH.
BENEDICT'S LIKE, NO, NO, NO.
NO, I'M NOT GONNA--I'M NOT GONNA
DEFECT TO THE BRITISH SIDE.
THAT'S INSANE.
GEORGE WASHINGTON'S MY DADDY,
KIND OF.
PEGGY SAYS, LOOK, I HAVE
A FRIEND IN THE BRITISH ARMY,
JOHN ANDRE.
BENEDICT'S LIKE, IS THAT GUY
YOUR EX-BOYFRIEND?
PEGGY'S LIKE, WELL, I MEAN,
BENEDICT, IF YOU REALLY
WANT TO BE WITH ME,
BE MORE CONFIDENT.
AND BENEDICT'S LIKE, YEAH.
YEAH, I AM GOING TO BETRAY
THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE I LOVE YOU,
AND I'M GOING TO PROVE TO YOU
THAT I AM NOT JEALOUS,
AND MAKES LOVE TO HIS WIFE.
AND SHE'S LIKE, I LOVE IT.
I LOVE BEING A SPY.
THIS IS SO GREAT
BECAUSE I LOVE DRAMA.
I'M PEGGY SHIPPEN,
LIKE, WHAT AN ADVENTURE.